ces gels pour quoi on marche tâcherai
les clés au mahb alliage
un qi hors norme excellents résultats
chez les marines que tu as laissé tomber
drogue d'éliminer
pas un seul boulot et qui ont donc père
m'a sauvé la vie il a dicté la proie
idéale jeunes gens je viens d'avoir une
journée plutôt épuisante alors quelle
que soit votre différend avec existe et
je suis sûr qu'il est tout à fait fondée
j'apprécierais que vous nous laisser
tranquille qu'il reste en dehors de sa
grand père tu attires mal
c'est assez manière que l'on juge un
homme vous savez ce que ça veut dire
alors je vais éclairer votre lanterne
on va traîner là toute la journée où est
ce qu'on va se battre
franchement navré j'avais besoin de
décompresser
que vois tu moi je vois du potentiel
lindemann est une agence internationale
de renseignement opérant au plus haut
niveau de discrétion si tu es prêt à
adapter tu peux te transformer en
espiens jeu ça te dit ah ouais
vous allez embarquer pour le plus
dangereux des entretiens d'embauché du
monde on est ici pour évaluer vos
limites pour affiner vos techniques
vous entraîner à lutter contre le mal
si vous mettez du sang sur le tapis et
vaillac à l'enlever le tapis
la vue du sang supporte pas
vous avez eu pitié du point
il a autant le profil kingman que les
autres mais en mieux
l'humanité est un virus et moi je suis
le remède à dire est que pas mal de gens
vont mourir
ça jean nirina
etc
non
espèce d'enfoiré